.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Stimmengewirr, Explosion *
* Schüsse *
Spezialkräfte der Schweizer Armee
üben den Ernstfall.
Man muss im Hinterkopf behalten,
dass es Realität werden kann.
Dafür sind wir da -
dass wir dann bereit sind.
Die Schweizer Armee wird sich wieder
auf die Verteidigung ausrichten.
Die Schweizer Armee
soll wieder lernen zu kämpfen.
So wie einst.
Und dann sind wir auf gutem Weg
zur besten Armee der Welt.
Ich schwöre es.
Bezüglich Verteidigungsfähigkeit ist
sie sicher nicht die beste der Welt.
Eine friedliche Welt, die ohne Armeen
auskommt - ein Traum in Trümmern.
Ich habe nie an den ewigen Frieden
in Europa geglaubt.
Europa hat sich entwaffnet -
und sieht sich nun mit einer Rückkehr
der Geschichte konfrontiert.
Europa kann sich
bei seiner Verteidigung
nicht einfach auf die USA verlassen.
Viele Länder in Europa
haben höchstens für drei Tage,
vielleicht eine Woche Munition.
Was viele nicht mehr für möglich
hielten, ist wieder Realität:
ein Krieg in Europa.
Das ist nicht
die Zukunft des Krieges.
Aber wir bekommen einen Eindruck
von künftigen Konflikten.
Was bedeutet diese neue Realität
für die Schweiz?
Wir müssen bereit sein,
uns zu wehren -
gegen was auch immer kommen könnte.
Militärs und Forscher
treffen sich nahe Genf.
"ARCHE"
heisst die jährliche Veranstaltung
von armasuisse und ETH Zürich.
Beide Welten sollen zusammenkommen -
zum gegenseitigen Nutzen.
Was die Wissenschaft entwickle
und hier präsentiere,
werde die Armee ausschliesslich
zur Katastrophenhilfe nutzen,
nie zum Kampf, wird versichert.
Es braucht indes wenig Fantasie,
um sich vorzustellen,
dass sich solche Technologien
auch als Waffen einsetzen liessen.
Ich habe den Eindruck, es wäre
nicht schwierig, das zu missbrauchen.
I mean ...
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich denke, es wäre nicht so einfach.
Sie würden dieses Ding
schon von Weitem kommen sehen.
Und es macht viel Lärm.
Es gäbe noch viel zu tun,
um daraus eine effektive Waffe
zu entwickeln.
Alles Ansichtssache.
Das Beispiel Ukraine zeigt,
wie einfach sich z.B. Drohnen
einsetzen lassen:
Sie bestimmen
die Koordinaten von Zielen.
Oder sie fliegen Kamikaze-Aktionen.
* Explosion *
Mitte August 2023:
Armeechef Süssli
redet von "Zäsur" und "Zeitenwende"
und präsentiert den Medien
seine Zukunftsvision.
Die Nutzung neuer Technologien
ist einer von drei Kernpunkten.
Wir haben in der Schweiz
eine gute Ausgangslage -
als Technologiestandort,
mit Wirtschaft,
Start-ups und Hochschulen -,
um die Chancen der Technologie
zu nutzen.
Alle vorhandenen Chancen nutzen,
indem das Wissen der Forscher
gezielt angezapft wird,
verrät uns der Armeechef später.
Die Schweizer Armee
gründete letztes Jahr
die Firma Swiss Innovation Forces.
Sie soll die Verbindung bilden
zu Start-ups, Universitäten
und Hochschulen, um zu erkennen,
welche Technologien
auch in der Armee
bedeutend sein könnten.
Und umgekehrt:
Wenn die Armee ein Bedürfnis hat,
kann die Firma das mit der Hilfe
dieser Partner umsetzen.
Wofür die Armee dieses Wissen
einsetzt, wird sich zeigen.
* Sirenenheulen *
Der 24. Februar 2022.
Seither sind viele Gewissheiten
ins Wanken geraten.
Am Rande Europas
herrscht wieder Krieg.
Und in der Schweiz fragen sich viele:
Was hätte unser Militär einer
solchen Aggression entgegenzusetzen?
"Kaum etwas", sagte der Armeechef
kurz nach Russlands Angriff offen:
Ich weiss nicht,
auf welches Szenario
er sich bei dieser Aussage stützte.
Eine Zahl zu nennen,
wäre nicht seriös.
Fakt ist:
Was heisst das konkret?
Unsere Armee ist das Produkt
der Armee XXI aus 2004.
Damals richtete man die Armee aus
auf die wahrscheinlichsten Einsätze.
Die Verteidigung wurde nur noch
als Kompetenz erhalten.
Am Anfang sprach man
von fünf bis acht Brigaden.
Heute haben wir noch zwei bis drei,
die nicht voll ausgerüstet sind.
Das bedeutet: Die Armee weiss
zwar noch, wie Verteidigung geht,
aber sie kann sie als Gesamtsystem
kaum mehr gewährleisten.
Obwohl genau das
laut Verfassung ihr Auftrag wäre:
Die Armee
hat verschiedene Aufgaben.
Eine ist laut Verfassung
die zivile Behördenunterstützung
in Katastrophen- und Krisenfällen.
Das kann die Armee sehr gut,
was sie in vergangenen Krisen
schon zeigte.
Während der Covid-Krise
oder bei Unwetterkatastrophen
hat sie immer geholfen.
Der andere Auftrag
ist die Verteidigung des Landes.
Darauf wurde die Armee
in den letzten Jahrzehnten
weniger ausgerichtet.
Darum haben wir einen Nachholbedarf
in der Verteidigungsfähigkeit.
Ein Besuch in Brüssel zeigt:
Nicht nur die Schweiz,
sondern ganz Europa
hat das Kämpfen weitgehend verlernt.
Die EU ist bemüht
um eine gemeinsame Aussen-,
Sicherheits-
und Verteidigungspolitik,
beraten durch einen Militärausschuss,
dem alle Generalstabschefs
der EU-Armeen angehören.
Robert Brieger leitet das Gremium und
ist damit der ranghöchste EU-General.
Nach dem Kalten Krieg
kam es zu Abrüstungen.
Es wurde sehr stark
sowohl in die Infrastruktur
als auch in Material
und Personal eingegriffen.
Das betrifft
die meisten Streitkräfte in Europa.
Diese Streitkräfte
benötigen meiner Einschätzung nach
ein Jahrzehnt,
um eine Verteidigungsfähigkeit
wiederherzustellen,
die einer tatsächlichen Resilienz
entspricht.
Ganz anders die Truppen der USA,
der letzten verbliebenen Supermacht.
Sie leistet sich
die stärkste Armee der Welt.
Die USA blicken schon lange
sorgenvoll nach Europa,
das sich stark entmilitarisiert hat.
Das Institute for the Study of War,
einer der weltweit führenden
Militär-Thinktanks.
Hierzulande werde Europa als naiv
und geschichtsblind wahrgenommen,
erzählt uns Kimberly Kagan,
die Gründerin und Leiterin
des Institutes.
Zeiten des Friedens sind selten.
Zeiten des Krieges sind normal.
Die Geschichte hat uns gezeigt,
dass Krieg ein Teil von dem ist,
wie Menschen Politik machen.
Der Militärwissenschaftler Carl
von Clausewitz drückte es so aus:
"Krieg ist die Fortsetzung
der Politik mit anderen Mitteln."
Freiheit gebe es nicht umsonst,
sie müsse verteidigt werden,
auch militärisch.
Diese Logik
blieb in den USA stets präsent.
Das Weisse Haus setzte immer auf eine
Mischung aus Zuckerbrot und Peitsche.
Auch zu Zeiten von Präsident Obama.
I'm also pleased to nominate
General David Petraeus.
Unter ihm stieg General
David Petraeus, hier rechts im Bild,
zum führenden Militär
und späteren CIA-Direktor auf.
I'll start recording,
if that's okay for you.
That's great.
Krieg verhindert man
durch Abschreckung.
Diese Abschreckung
hängt von zwei Faktoren ab:
wie der Gegner unsere Fähigkeiten
und unseren Willen,
diese einzusetzen, einschätzt.
Wir müssen dafür sorgen,
dass es glasklar ist,
dass wir die Fähigkeiten haben
und willens sind, diese einzusetzen,
um NATO-Länder zu verteidigen.
Ein Rückfall
in längst vergangen geglaubte Zeiten.
Spezialkräfte der Schweizer Armee
bereiten sich auf eine Übung vor.
Das Szenario:
Eine bewaffnete Gruppe hat sich
in einem Haus im Wald verschanzt.
Bravo One
nähert sich von der Innenseite an.
Von dieser Strasse.
- Genau.
Bleibt Bravo Two in Deckung?
Bis wir an der Fassade sind,
oder bis wir Kontakt aufnehmen?
Wenn etwas in der Ruine ist,
bleiben wir in Deckung und warten.
Wachtmeister Nils Dörr
hat die Matur gemacht
und will bald
ein Geografiestudium anfangen.
Er hat schon lange vor seiner
Aushebung intensiv trainiert,
um sich in Topform zu bringen
und es zur Elitetruppe zu schaffen:
zu den Grenadieren.
Nicht immer den einfachsten Weg
zu wählen ist ein guter Grundsatz.
Bei den Spezialkräften
sind die Leute motiviert
und man macht eine gute Ausbildung.
Ich freute mich aufs Militär.
Und wenn ich gehe, dann will ich
etwas mit motivierten Leuten tun
und eine gute Ausbildung geniessen.
Wer zu den Spezialkräften will,
muss eine strenge Selektion
durchlaufen,
denn sie würden im Falle eines
Krieges an vorderster Front stehen.
Langsam, langsam.
Nach hinten. Zurück.
Soldaten würden kämpfen.
Das klingt selbstverständlich,
ist es aber nicht.
So hat eine Umfrage kürzlich ergeben:
Die Zahl erscheint tief,
es hängt aber von der Situation ab.
Ein wichtiger Aspekt ist
die Unterstützung der Bevölkerung.
Wenn man spürt,
dass die breite Bevölkerung
verteidigen will, der Wille da ist,
kommen auch mehr.
Achtung!
Die Spezialkräfte bereiten sich
auf einen Ernstfall vor,
von dem alle hoffen,
dass er nie eintritt.
Würde die Schweiz angegriffen,
wäre nicht nur
der fehlende Kampfeswille
von grossen Teilen der Truppe
ein Problem.
Die Armee
hätte auch viel zu wenig Leute.
Eine Lösungsansatz auf dem Weg
zur Besserung könnte sein,
künftig nicht nur die Männer,
sondern auch die Frauen
in die Pflicht zu nehmen.
Eine obligatorische Dienstplicht für
Frauen ist nicht die erste Option.
In Zeiten von Gleichberechtigung
wäre das doch naheliegend.
Ich bin für Gleichberechtigung,
aber die haben wir an vielen anderen
Orten auch noch nicht erreicht.
Ich würde dort ansetzen.
Der Exodus der Männer
hält derweil an.
Die Armee -
das sind letztlich Menschen.
Es ist ein People Business.
Die grösste Herausforderung
der Armeeführung
ist die Alimentierung der Armee.
Rückblende ins Jahr 2009.
Guten Tag.
Die Bereitschaft,
einen Zivildienst zu leisten,
der deutlich länger dauert
als der Militärdienst,
gilt ab jetzt als ausreichender
Nachweis für einen Gewissenskonflikt.
Ein Gesuch reicht - und man ist weg.
Auf gut Deutsch gesagt
sassen wir in den WKs
die meiste Zeit einfach herum.
Ich kann meine Zeit
besser einsetzen.
Marsch! Links ...
Die Schweiz
hat zwar weiter eine Wehrpflicht,
aber seit 2009
faktisch eine Freiwilligen-Armee.
Die ersten Monate sind dramatisch,
wir verlieren zu viele
an den Zivildienst.
Das muss man im Auge behalten.
Hält der Trend an,
braucht es dringend Korrekturen.
Korrekturen blieben aus,
der Trend hielt an:
Gut 6'000 Männer gehen Jahr für Jahr
in den Zivildienst.
Das ist in erster Linie
Aufgabe der Armee.
Die Armee attraktiv zu machen,
damit junge Menschen sehen,
Militärdienst zu leisten
bringt ihnen etwas.
Erstens kann man etwas
zur Sicherheit des Landes beitragen.
Zweitens kann die Dienstleistung
einem selbst etwas bringen,
indem man eine Ausbildung erhält
und in jungen Jahren
Führungserfahrung sammeln kann,
was einem im Berufsleben
und im zivilen Leben etwas bringt.
Wenn es uns gelingt,
das besser zu zeigen,
und wir uns selber verbessern -
nicht nur kommunikativ,
auch in der Sache -,
bin ich überzeugt,
dass sich mehr junge Leute bereit-
erklären, Militärdienst zu leisten.
Den Weg in den Zivildienst
zu erschweren ist keine Option?
Die erste Option ist,
selber besser zu werden,
bevor man versucht,
woanders etwas zu erschweren.
* Dramatische Musik *
Ein Propagandafilm der Schweizer
Armee aus den 1960er-Jahren.
Damals problemlos alimentiert mit den
Söhnen der Aktivdienst-Generation.
Der Zweite Weltkrieg war noch Teil
des kollektiven Gedächtnisses.
Wie Adolf Hitler 1939
Europas brüchigen Frieden brach.
Wie die Schweizer Soldaten
ohne Fliegerabwehr
in den Aktivdienst einrückten.
Die Schweiz war unvorbereitet,
ihre Führung mutlos und resigniert.
Bis er kam und dem Volk den Glauben
an die eigenen Stärken zurückgab:
General Henri Guisan.
Verteidigen heisst in diesem Falle:
nicht nur halten,
sondern sich mit aller Kraft
zu schlagen,
zu zerstören, sein Leben
so teuer wie möglich zu verkaufen.
Rund 500 Offiziere -
vom Major an aufwärts -
brachen im Juli 1940 auf
Richtung Rütli.
Das Rütli als Wahrzeichen
einer wehrhaften Schweiz
unterstrich General Guisans
Widerstandsrede.
* Sirenenheulen *
* Explosion *
General Guisans Plan war tollkühn:
Er propagierte den Rückzug
der Truppen ins Réduit.
Tief hinein in die Schweizer Berge.
* Bedrückende Musik *
Grosse Teile des Landes
hätte man geopfert.
Alte, Frauen und Kinder, sie alle
hätte die Armee zurückgelassen,
dem Feind
praktisch schutzlos ausgeliefert.
Eine traumatische Erfahrung, die sich
keinesfalls wiederholen sollte,
sagt Georg Häsler, Sicherheitsexperte
der "Neuen Zürcher Zeitung"
und Oberst in der Armee.
Die Lehre aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
war: Man wollte bereit sein.
1939 war man nicht bereit und
musste sich ins Réduit zurückziehen.
Das wollte man unbedingt verhindern.
Es folgt der Kalte Krieg.
* Russisch *
... a worldwide nuclear war.
Die Gefahr eines Atomkrieges
ist nun omnipräsent.
Man war sich bewusst,
dass eine umfassende
Landesverteidigung sehr teuer ist.
Die Schweiz
gab dafür sehr viel Geld aus.
Darum gab es Überlegungen,
mit einer Atombombe eine
abschreckende Wirkung zu erzielen.
Die Atombombe war ein finanzielles
Argument für weniger Ausgaben.
* Marschmusik *
Die Armee 61 bekommt schliesslich
keine Atombombe.
Dafür 800'000 Männer unter Waffen
und über 10 Mrd. Fr. Jahresbudget.
In den 60er-Jahren hiess es:
"Die Schweiz hat keine Armee,
sie ist eine."
Die Armee durchdrang
auch die Gesellschaft.
Das hält bis weit
in die 1980er-Jahre an.
Ich bin für das Militär.
Ich bin für eine Verteidigung.
Wenn man die Gelegenheit hat,
sich das anzuschauen -
warum nicht?
Bilder aus Dübendorf
aus dem Jahr 1986.
Wir wollen sehen,
was über unsere Steuergelder
in die Armee investiert wird.
Der Armee
kommt derweil der Feind abhanden.
Denn der Kalte Krieg beginnt zu tauen
und ganz neue,
grundsätzliche Fragen werden möglich.
Man durfte plötzlich auch die
Existenz der Armee infrage stellen.
Man durfte auch Dogmen hinterfragen.
Das prägte die zweite Hälfte
der 80er-Jahre stark.
* Stimmengewirr, Jubel *
1989: Die Berliner Mauer fällt.
Immer mehr Menschen fragen sich:
Wozu braucht es jetzt noch Militär?
In der Schweiz kommt eine Initiative
zur Abschaffung der Armee
zur Abstimmung.
Die Gruppe für eine Schweiz
ohne Armee, kurz GSoA, findet,
die Schweiz sollte besser in die
aktive Friedensförderung investieren.
Die Armee frisst sehr viel Geld:
jedes Jahr über 10 Mrd. Fr.
Genau mit diesem Geld
könnte man dazu beitragen,
dass ein Krieg
unwahrscheinlicher wird.
Zwei Wochen nach dem Mauerfall
wird abgestimmt.
Der Zwischenstand bei der Armee-
Abschaffungs-Initiative:
Das war ein Schock
für die Schweizer Armee.
Davon erholte sie sich
bis vor Kurzem nicht.
Es stellte Selbstverständnisse
sowie die Position der Armee
innerhalb der Gesellschaft infrage.
Jo Lang, einer der Mitinitianten,
meinte,
man habe die heilige Kuh
zwar nicht geschlachtet,
ihr aber den Heiligenschein
weggenommen.
* Schüsse *
Gut 30 Jahre später
herrscht Krieg in der Ukraine.
Das hat Auswirkungen auf die Ein-
stellung der Schweizer Bevölkerung.
Welche Schlüsse
sollen Europas Armeen
aus den Bildern, die uns täglich aus
der Ukraine erreichen, nun ziehen?
Zuerst und v.a.
muss in die Bereitschaft
investiert werden.
Sicherstellen,
dass die bestehenden Waffensysteme,
seien es Panzer, Schiffe, Flugzeuge,
einsatzfähig sind.
Und dass jene, die diese Systeme
bedienen, trainiert und bereit sind.
Dann unbedingt
die Munitionsbestände auffüllen.
Und schliesslich
braucht es eine Transformation:
weg von wenigen grossen
und unbeweglichen Plattformen,
hin zu vielen kleinen, beweglichen.
Diese werden zunehmend
unbemannt sein:
am Boden, in der Luft,
im Wasser und im Cyberspace.
Die Digitalisierung
der Schweizer Streitkräfte
soll in den kommenden Jahren adaptiv,
sozusagen in rollender Planung,
vorangetrieben werden.
Milliarden
sollen in neue Technologien fliessen,
denn sie würden die Kriegsführung
revolutionieren,
ist die Armee überzeugt.
Die neuen Mittel
erhöhen v.a. die Effizienz.
Das Gefechtsfeld wird gläsern sein,
sowohl durch Satellitenaufklärung
als auch durch Drohnen.
Alle Truppen,
die sich am Boden bewegen,
müssen kleiner und schneller werden
und sich besser tarnen können.
Es wird ein Nebeneinander sein
von neuen Technologien
und dem Bestehenden.
Das Parlament wird sich im kommenden
Jahr mit Süsslis Vision befassen.
Nichts davon ist bisher abgesegnet -
auch die Kosten nicht.
Der Aufwuchs der Armee,
das Wiedererlangen
der Verteidigungsfähigkeit
wird insgesamt
bis zu 50 Mrd. Fr. kosten.
Mitte August 2023:
Die Armee präsentiert sich der
Bevölkerung an einer Ausstellung.
Ich finde sie sehr professionell.
- Sehr innovativ.
Man dürfe die Bedeutung dieser neuen
Technologien auch nicht überschätzen,
warnt derweil
die Expertin aus den USA.
Wenn wir an das Aufkommen
der Luftwaffen zurückdenken,
als strategisches Bombardieren
möglich wurde,
hörte man, Armeen
werde es bald nicht mehr brauchen.
Es gab also schon immer
die Hoffnung,
dass ein technologischer Fortschritt
den Krieg so verändern wird,
dass man ihn
antiseptisch führen kann.
Sauber, aus weiter Distanz,
mit geringen Kosten.
Technologie
verändert den Krieg natürlich,
aber er wird weiterhin
von bewaffneten Menschen gekämpft.
(Alle)
Guten Tag. Bonjour. Buongiorno.
Wir kommen zur Befehlsausgabe
für die Mission 4.18.
Für die Spezialkräfte wird es ernst.
Ich komme zu den Aufträgen.
Detachement Alpha.
Nimmt und hält auf Befehl Caramba
das Zielobjekt Emerald und Helium.
Heute Nacht müssen sie ausrücken
und eine bewaffnete Gruppe,
gespielt von Kameraden, überwältigen.
Diese haben sich
in einer Hütte im Wald verschanzt.
Und zum Schluss - Sie wissen es:
der Uhren-Check.
Drei, zwei, eins - go.
Gut.
Wachtmeister Nils Dörr
und seine Kameraden
decken sich mit Material ein: mit
Munition, Blend- und Handgranaten.
Natürlich alle nicht scharf,
damit sich niemand verletzt.
Es ist eine Übung für uns.
Es geht darum,
was wir in der RS gelernt haben,
praktisch umzusetzen.
Von Angst kann man bei einer Übung
nicht reden. Nervös schon.
Wie schwer ist das alles?
Auswendig weiss ich es nicht.
Das ist ca. 5 kg.,
das hier auch, die ist 15 kg.
Ja.
Die ist 3,5 bis 4 kg.
Es kommt schon etwas zusammen.
- Sie tragen über 25 kg.
Das sicher.
Da müssen Sie fit sein.
- Darum wird selektioniert.
* Militärmusik *
Ueli Maurer Anfang 2010,
kurz nach seinem Amtsantritt.
Am Kadertag
mit Chefbeamten und Offizieren
wird gute Stimmung verbreitet -
auch wenn alle wissen, dass die Armee
in einem lamentablen Zustand ist.
(Mann) Eins! Zwei!
Gut. Uns ist warm. Merci.
* Lachen *
Die Armee
steht an einem Wendepunkt.
In den nächsten Jahren
muss es uns gelingen,
die notwendigen Mittel aufzutreiben
und die Leute zu motivieren.
Sie, Ihre Kader,
unsere WK-Soldaten.
Dann sind wir auf gutem Weg
zur besten Armee der Welt.
Die Armee musste in den vergangenen
30 Jahren sparen, wo sie konnte,
etwa indem Atomschutzunterstände
ausser Betrieb genommen wurden.
Der harte Kern der Armee wurde
bis aufs Gerippe runter abgespart.
Das Militär schien nur zu kosten,
aber kaum noch einen Nutzen zu haben.
Was sich entsorgen liess,
wurde darum entsorgt.
Angefangen hat der Niedergang
der Schweizer Armee
nach dem Kalten Krieg.
Damals wird aus der Armee 61
die Armee 95.
Soldaten.
Die Mannstärke wird stark reduziert:
von 600'000 auf 400'000.
Material, Infrastruktur und Fahrzeuge
werden im grossen Stil abgebaut.
Die grosse Ost-West-Konfrontation,
die es im Kalten Krieg gab,
ist so
eigentlich nicht mehr möglich.
Boris Jelzin,
der damalige russische Präsident,
scheint kaum noch jemandem
gefährlich werden zu können.
Die Spannungen von einst
haben sich in Wohlgefallen aufgelöst.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Auf Kaspar Villiger folgt 1995
Adolf Ogi als Verteidigungsminister.
Ogi richtet die Armee in den
folgenden Jahren völlig neu aus.
Die neue Armee
heisst Schweizer Armee XXI.
Swiss Army XXI.
Der aktive Truppenbestand
wird noch mal drastisch reduziert:
von 360'000 auf 120'000.
Und die Armee bekommt einen neuen
Fokus: weg von der Verteidigung.
Schützen und helfen
stand im Vordergrund.
Nur eine kleine Minderheit
kämpfte noch.
Und das ist bis heute so geblieben.
Die Soldaten stampfen nun
Schneepisten am Lauberhornrennen.
Sie kommen am World Economic Forum
in Davos zum Einsatz.
Halt!
Umdrehen!
Und sie fördern den Frieden
in Missionen im Ausland.
"Sicherheit durch Kooperation"
heisst fortan das Motto.
Die Logik dahinter: geben, um
nötigenfalls auch nehmen zu können.
Der Gedanke,
dass man sich engagiert,
um auch Sicherheitsleistungen
zu erhalten,
wird bis heute weitergelebt.
SWISSCOY im Kosovo
ist eine Leistung,
die die Schweiz der NATO erbringt,
um von deren Sicherheit
profitieren zu können.
Dieser Gedanke
wurde nicht aufgegeben.
Nur wird nicht darüber diskutiert,
man nennt den Grund nicht.
Die NATO:
ein Verteidigungsbündnis
von 31 europäischen
und nordamerikanischen Staaten.
An ihrem 70. Geburtstag
war sie noch heillos zerstritten.
US-Präsident Donald Trump
drohte gar mit Austritt.
Erst der Krieg in der Ukraine
brachte die Wende.
Putin wollte Russland
wieder gross machen,
indem er seinen Nachbarn überfiel.
Doch er machte
die NATO wieder gross.
Putin ist das grösste Geschenk
für die NATO
seit dem Ende des Kalten Krieges.
Heute ist die NATO so geeint
und stark wie lange nicht mehr.
Und für die neutrale Schweiz
stellt sich die Frage,
ob sie künftig enger kooperieren soll
mit dem Verteidigungsbündnis.
Eine aktuelle Umfrage
der ETH Zürich zeigt:
Würde die Schweiz der NATO beitreten,
müsste sie ihre Neutralität aufgeben.
Weiterhin undenkbar.
Wir dürfen und wollen uns nicht
in fremde militärische Konflikte
einbringen bzw. einmischen.
Das tun wir nicht.
Somit respektieren wir
die Neutralität.
Klar ist auch:
Während Friedenszeiten
dürfen wir in der Zusammenarbeit
mit anderen Ländern
keine Fakten schaffen, die uns
später zur Einmischung zwingen.
Solange wir nicht
der NATO beitreten -
mit Art. 5 würden wir da
beistandspflichtig werden.
Unter dieser Schwelle
ist alles möglich.
Es ist alles möglich,
sofern wir uns nicht in fremde
militärische Konflikte einmischen.
Wir können zusammen üben,
müssen aber klar festhalten,
dass wir im Ernstfall
nicht werden unterstützen können.
Die Verteidigungsministerin
möchte sich also der NATO annähern,
aber neutral bleiben.
Würde die Schweiz angegriffen,
wohl mit der NATO kooperieren,
aber vorher nicht beitreten.
Und künftig jährlich 1 % des BIP
in die Armee investieren,
während die NATO-Länder
das Doppelte anstreben.
Die Schweiz profitiert
vom Sicherheitsschirm der NATO.
Sie geniesst die Vorteile eines
friedlichen und blühenden Europas,
ohne sich genügend
an den Kosten zu beteiligen.
Es wird immer gewisse Länder geben,
die von den bestehenden Umständen
profitieren.
Es wäre toll, wenn die Schweiz
der NATO beitreten würde.
Z.B. in der Luft leiste die Schweiz
in Kooperation mit dem umliegenden
Ausland einen wichtigen Beitrag,
sagt die Armee:
mit dem Luftpolizeidienst.
Mario Thöni, Militärpilot,
in Payerne stationiert.
Er und seine Kollegen stellen sicher,
dass die Schweizer Luftwaffe
stets einsatzbereit ist.
Wir sind dreieinhalb Tage
auf Pikett.
Wir sind Tag und Nacht bereit,
innerhalb von 15 Min.
in die Luft zu gehen.
Während der Wartezeiten gibt es
diverse Büroarbeiten zu erledigen.
* Alarmton *
* Telefon *
Ja?
(Mann) Hallo, hier spricht
* unverständlich *.
Wir setzen Alert 5.
A simulated mission ...
(Thöni) Copy. Hammer 1,
Single Aircraft, set Alert 5.
Korrekt.
- Copy. Tschau.
Dieser Alarm ist nicht echt,
sondern zu Übungszwecken.
Attention! Hammer 1,
Single Aircraft, setting Alert 5.
Thöni und seine Kollegen fliegen
immer wieder sog. Hot Missions:
eine Art Blaulicht-Einsätze
bei der Verletzung
des Schweizer Luftraumes
oder wenn die Luftverkehrsregeln
grob missachtet werden.
Die F/A-18,
die hier zum Einsatz kommen,
wurden in den 1990er-Jahren
beschafft.
Ein zentrales Kriterium bei der Wahl
sei die Möglichkeit gewesen,
problemlos mit dem Ausland
kooperieren zu können.
Die sog. Interoperabilität.
Einerseits beim Luftpolizeidienst,
aber auch im Falle eines Konfliktes,
sagt der Sicherheitsexperte
der "NZZ".
Die F/A-18 wäre natürlich
eine Möglichkeit gewesen,
in einer verschlechterten
Sicherheitssituation
sofort mit der NATO
kooperieren zu können.
Darum wurde damals
dieser Kampfjet gewählt.
Damit hätte man eine robuste
Fähigkeit einbringen können.
Mit dem F-35
haben wir heute die gleiche Logik.
Ja, was in den 90er-Jahren
der F/A-18 war, ist heute der F-35.
Das Hauptevaluationskriterium war:
das beste Flugzeug für unser Land
zum besten Preis.
Diese Kriterien waren erfüllt.
Die Interoperabilität
ist etwas Positives,
davon können wir profitieren.
Der Luftpolizeidienst arbeitet jetzt
schon mit Nachbarländern zusammen.
Wir können die Sicherheit am WEF
ohne diese Zusammenarbeit
nicht gewährleisten.
Und das funktioniert sehr gut.
Damit das so bleibt, beschafft
die Schweiz nun den F-35 aus den USA.
Im Ernstfall
soll dieses Kampfflugzeug
auch Ziele im Ausland
ausschalten können -
allein oder im Verbund mit der NATO.
Ein neues Szenario,
das sich "Air Interdiction" nennt
und bis vor Kurzem noch geheim war.
Heute werden diese Offensiv-
strategien offen ausgesprochen.
Wenn man wartet,
bis die Rakete im Haus einschlägt,
brauchen wir
keine Verteidigung mehr.
Man muss dafür sorgen,
dass man sie aufhalten kann,
bevor sie ihr Ziel erreicht.
Das ist neu:
sich verteidigen
mit offensiven Aktionen im Ausland.
Ich würde mir nicht mehr anmassen,
ein Szenario auszuschliessen.
Wir müssen uns
auf alle Bedrohungen vorbereiten.
Der Krieg in der Ukraine
hat offenbar alles verändert.
Auch in Finnland.
General Timo Kivinen, der finnische
Armeechef, besucht seine Truppe.
Sie hätten immer eine starke
Verteidigungsarmee gehabt, sagt er.
Jetzt, da das Nachbarland Russland
im Krieg ist,
wollte sich Finnland nicht mehr nur
auf die eigenen Soldaten verlassen.
Eine überwältigende Mehrheit sprach
sich für einen NATO-Beitritt aus.
Die Unterstützung
für einen NATO-Beitritt
war vor der russischen Aggression
in Februar 2022 unter 30 %.
Zehn Tage nach der Invasion
lag sie bei 70 % und stieg weiter.
Würden Sie anderen Ländern auch
eine grössere Kooperation empfehlen?
Diese Diskussion
sollte jedes Land intern führen.
Die finnische Armee
müsste ihr Land künftig
nicht mehr allein verteidigen,
sondern in einer grossen Allianz.
Mit dem NATO-Beitritt haben sich die
Finnen aber auch dazu verpflichtet,
ihre Verteidigungsausgaben
massiv zu erhöhen.
Der Wunschzettel des Armeechefs
ist bereits lang.
Eine zeitgemässe Verteidigung
braucht eine Kombination:
High-End-Technologien
und grosse Reserven.
So können wir zu Beginn einer Krise
schnell agieren,
aber auch lange durchhalten.
Was wir alle in Europa
jetzt dringend tun müssen:
unsere Munitionslager auffüllen.
Das machen wir auch.
Nach Jahrzehnten der Abrüstung wird
wieder auf breiter Front aufgerüstet.
Und die Armeen Europas
suchen den Schulterschluss.
Das Schweizer Militär
formuliert es so:
In Europa gibt es keine Beispiele
für einen Alleingang.
Das nächste Beispiel ist Israel,
aber die besitzen Atomwaffen.
Israel,
ein Land umzingelt von Feinden
und darum quasi
zum Alleingang verdammt.
Dieser Alleingang ist teuer:
Israel investiert 6 % seines BIP
in die Verteidigung,
also gut sechsmal mehr
als die Schweiz.
Männer müssen fast drei Jahre
durchgehend ins Militär, Frauen zwei.
Eine eigene Hightech-Rüstungs-
industrie versorgt die Truppe laufend
mit dem neusten Equipment.
Eine Armee für einen Alleingang
fit zu machen, sei sehr komplex,
sagt General Amos Yadlin,
der ehemalige Luftwaffenchef.
Die Kunst besteht darin,
alle Elemente des Krieges
miteinander zu kombinieren:
den Boden, die Luft, das Wasser,
den Cyber- und den Informationsraum.
Natürlich
braucht man Präzisionswaffen,
aber diese sind wertlos,
wenn man nicht über ausgezeichnete
Geheimdienste verfügt:
Die müssen den Präzisionswaffen
die genauen Ziele liefern.
Es braucht
einen fähigen Oberbefehlshaber,
professionelle Kaderleute und
eine funktionierende Befehlskette.
Zudem viel Training.
Es dauert Jahre,
so eine Armee aufzubauen.
Im Juni 1967 zeigte Israel der Welt,
zu was eine solche Armee
imstande ist.
In nur sechs Tagen
setzte sich Israel gegen Ägypten,
Jordanien und Syrien durch.
Der sog. Sechstagekrieg:
eine blutige Machtdemonstration.
Kleine Länder müssen stark sein,
sonst werden sie attackiert
oder annektiert.
Wenn ihr einen langen Frieden wollt,
bereitet euch auf den Krieg vor.
Dann überlegt es sich
euer Feind zweimal.
Die brutalen Logiken der Abschreckung
kehren nun auch nach Europa zurück.
Darüber hätten wir gerne
mit dem russischen Botschafter
in Bern gesprochen -
und über die Frage, ob sich die
Schweiz vor Russland fürchten muss.
Er sagt aus Zeitgründen ab.
Der Nachrichtendienst des Bundes
stellt indes fest:
Ich will mich auf kein Land
und auf keine Region fokussieren.
Wir müssen bereit sein,
uns zu wehren -
gegen was auch immer kommen könnte.
2001 kam die Gefahr aus der Luft.
Seither galt Terror als die
konkreteste Gefahr für die Schweiz.
Ab 2001 ist eines der Themen
"the war on terror",
der Krieg gegen Terrorismus.
Terroranschläge wurden quasi als
das robusteste Szenario definiert.
Der Rest der Armee wurde zu einer
Hilfstruppe der Zivilbehörden.
Die Bedrohung durch Terror
ist hoch geblieben in Europa.
Armeen spielten in diesem Kontext
allerdings immer nur eine Nebenrolle.
Die Polizei stand im Fokus.
Etwa in Frankreich bewachten Soldaten
höchstens Infrastrukturen
oder patrouillierten.
Terrorabwehr ist grundsätzlich
Aufgabe der Zivilbehörde.
Wenn die Mittel nicht ausreichen,
unterstützt die Armee.
Wir kehren noch einmal zurück
nach Israel.
Zu JAMAS, einer Undercover-
Spezialeinheit der Polizei.
Profis, die den Kampf
gegen den Terror täglich üben.
* Schüsse *
Diese Männer sind Polizisten
und bekommen ihre Informationen
für Zugriffe vom Geheimdienst.
Wer Terror bekämpfen will,
muss also hier investieren:
in Spezialeinheiten der Polizei
und in den Geheimdienst.
Die Gegner sind in Israel klar,
im Gegensatz zur Schweiz,
wo es zwar generell
unsicherer geworden sein soll,
ansonsten
aber alles sehr diffus bleibt.
Sie können keinen konkreten Feind
benennen für die Zukunft?
Wir müssen
keinen konkreten Feind benennen.
Wir arbeiten
mit den potenziellen Bedrohungen.
Und diese nehmen in ganz Europa zu.
Die bauen sich über Jahre auf.
Das kann man gut beobachten.
Absichten hingegen
können sich schnell ändern.
* Unverständliche Funkdurchsage *
Morgens um 4 Uhr.
Der Höhepunkt der Übung der
Spezialkräfte der Schweizer Armee:
der Zugriff.
* Schüsse *
Sie üben, eine Terrorzelle
auszuheben, die sich verschanzt hat.
Eine Aufgabe,
die das Militär wohl auch künftig
getrost der Polizei überlassen kann.
(Mann) Ihr müsst ins Haus kommen.
Vier Männer down.
* Stimmengewirr, verzerrte Musik *
Auf welche Szenarien
sollen diese Soldaten
nun sinnvollerweise
vorbereitet werden?
Diese Frage stellt sich
für die ganze Armee.
Die politische Debatte darüber
hat gerade erst begonnen.
Ich bin sehr froh,
dass das Thema Sicherheit
wieder diskutiert wird.
Es ist wichtig,
dass sich die Politik
und die Bevölkerung bewusst sind,
dass Frieden,
wie es ihn Jahrzehnte gab,
nicht selbstverständlich ist.
Wir trainieren nicht zum Spass,
sondern für den Ernstfall.
Man muss im Hinterkopf behalten,
dass es Realität werden kann.
Dafür sind wir da -
dass wir dann bereit sind.
Wären Sie bereit,
Ihr Leben zu riskieren?
Absolut.
Dafür bin ich da.
Wie teuer
darf die Armee künftig sein?
Woher kommen die Leute,
um all die leeren Ränge zu füllen?
Und sollen die Soldaten die Schweiz
allein verteidigen können?
Oder in internationaler Kooperation?
Wohin soll es gehen
mit der Schweizer Armee der Zukunft?
Darüber wird nun
die Politik entscheiden müssen.
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2023